it was only this month that wind the
phone said goodbye to a daughter try me
and she set out for the UK 39 people
died in Essex a horrifying total this is
the toll on one family who believed
their daughter was among them
this is Tommy's father canal that the
yeah Mel account the movie in a Yamaha
BD Thank You Tommy
plan to work in a nail salon in the UK
and down between 1300 and 2,000 pounds a
month
she went from Vietnam by land to China
then flew to France her father says
paying about 31,000 pounds these are the
last distressing messages they received
from her not long before the lorry and
its cargo full of death were discovered
considable man no Mary gon love me
look why come time calm down dinner
sometime
Mary controllable menuhim if we come to
the theater then you can look happy you
know Mary consider becomes you know
becoming my bad news Illinois trauma is
one unconfirmed victim wind into an an
abuti none are also feared by their
relatives to be among the 39 and some
families have said that the lorry was
only one of a convoy of three taking
more than 100 people to the UK
British police have said official
identification of the dead will take
time thousands of miles away here back
home they are already mourning